-Our next guest can be seen
on his nationwide stand-up tour,
that includes a night
at the Vivint Arena
in Salt Lake City --
an Arena, oh, my goodness,
how fun --
November 24th.
Please welcome the very funny
Ryan Hamilton!
[ The Roots playing funk ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi. You're not
going to believe this.
I'm from Idaho.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Maybe you do believe that.
[ Laughter ]
It's strange.
That's enough to get a laugh
in New York City, really.
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't really register
here, you know?
It's just people go, right now,
are looking at me, going,
"This guy from Iowa
is pretty interesting."
[ Laughter ]
That's how it is.
I love this city,
but it's not my default setting,
you know?
There's a rhythm to this city
that I have to get into
and I can feel it coming.
My chest starts to tighten up,
my thoughts start to whirl.
It's like I'm getting
into double Dutch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I can feel it.
It's like,
"I'm going to New York.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to New York.
I'm in New York.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't touch me.
[ Cheering ]
I don't have any money.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hold the door, please.
Hold the door.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is a two-bedroom?
Are you out of your mind?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
But make no mistake --
this is an improvisational city.
I mean, you leave your house
and you're scatting, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Subway's down, Uber's surging.
I'm running.
[ Laughter ]
This is the only city you go,
"I guess I'm going to run."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
It's just another mode
of transportation.
[ Laughter ]
People just run here, you know?
And people get it.
"What happened?"
I ran 40 blocks.
People go, "Oh, I'm so sorry.
I had to run yesterday.
Isn't it terrible?"
[ Laughter ]
I saw a guy running on the
George Washington Bridge
and not an exercise guy...
[ Laughter ]
...a suit guy, just running.
If you see an exercise guy
on a bridge,
you think,
"That guy is ambitious."
But if you see
a suit guy running --
just about anywhere,
but especially on a bridge --
you think,
"That guy's in trouble."
[ Laughter ]
Where are you in your life that
you're in a suit and you go,
"I'm on the wrong side
of the river!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, no!
Not again!"
[ Cheering and applause ]
I think that guy's dead.
I don't know.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I saw a guy on the subway
holding a Citi Bike
and I can't stop thinking
about that guy.
[ Laughter ]
I was just looking at him like,
"I don't know
where you're going,
but I know there's a better way
to get there.
I know."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if you don't know,
Citi Bikes are these free bikes
we have around the city
that you pay for.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know them.
He was on public transportation
and holding
public transportation.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was so perplexing, you know?
What are you doing?
Did you pay twice?
[ Laughter ]
I don't understand.
It's very strange because we all
make our travel plan
in the morning, you know?
Like I'm going to take
this down and transfer there.
And this guy had to be like...
[ Laughter ]
..."I'm overwhelmed.
I don't know.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think I'm just going to pick
up the bike first, you know?
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to be
the only guy out there
without a bike, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And then I'll just take it
down there with me.
And once you get it down there,
you got to bring it back up.
[ Laughter ]
And then maybe I can get an Uber
and put it in the back of the
Uber, something like that.
[ Laughter ]
I just want to get somewhere
where I can ride this thing,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Been paying for it all day long.
This is a tough city
to get around.
You ever give someone directions
in New York City
and then, two blocks later,
just go...
[ Laughter ]
..."Oh, no.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think I killed
that foreign family.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They are so dead
and there's nothing I can do."
[ Laughter ]
I just want to call 911
and be like, "I'm so sorry.
There's this family
and I sent them west
at Port Authority
[ Laughter and applause ]
and all they wanted
was cheesecake
and now, I can't sleep."
[ Laughter ]
My family's concerned
about me out here
and they should be.
[ Laughter ]
If you're a criminal
and you see me walking around,
your thought is,
"It's going to be a good day."
[ Laughter ]
That's what you think.
"I'm going to hit my quota early
and clock out, you know?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Criminal half day.
[ Laughter ]
Like if I was ever on the phone
with my father,
walking around the city,
he'd always go,
"Son, where's your wallet?
Put your wallet
in your front pocket."
That was my dad's plan to foil
New York City's criminals.
[ Laughter ]
Just to switch my wallet
over into the unexpected pocket
you know?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know how this plays out,
if you get held up, you know?
it's like, "I hope
they don't come around.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I can't believe I'm getting
away with it right now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
My father's going
to be so proud."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Where's the wallet, man?!
Where's the --"
[ Snickers ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean --
[ Cheering ]
This guy has no clue!
What a rube, huh?
[ Laughter ]
I guess he's never been
to Idaho before.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
I'm Ryan Hamilton.
Thank you very much.
[ Whistling ]
-Oh, my gosh!
Thank you so much.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Ryan Hamilton!
That's how you do it
right there.
For more info,
go to ryanhamiltonlive.com.
We'll be right back.
Oh, my gosh!